hello everyone welcome to the mindscape
podcast I'm your host Sean Carol here at
mindscape you may have noticed we
occasionally talk about quantum
mechanics that's a favorite theme of
ours here and so one name that will
appear sometimes when talking about
quantum mechanics is that of verer
Heisenberg the early 20th century
physicist who actually was one of the
authors of the first fully formed theory
of quantum mechanics called Matrix
mechanics we also talk about philosophy
and if you're into talking about
philosophy a one name that will come up
is Emmanuel Kant the German philosopher
from the 18th century who wrote about
just everything in philosophy political
philosophy ethical philosophy Aesthetics
philosophy of science metaphysics
epistemology all those things and we did
in fact I had to check this I'll admit
but we have in fact mentioned Jorge Luis
bores the poet Spanish language poet
from South America from Argentina in
particular poet and short story writer
he was mentioned in the episode that we
did long ago with Alan Al Lightman Alan
Lightman mentioned that he was a fan of
the magical realists like Italo calino
bores and others forese is a wonderful
poetic imaginative writer who I can
hardly recommend to anyone who's a
mindscape fan but we haven't really
dwelt on him here on the podcast we
mentioned him very briefly in passing so
we certainly have never talked about all
three of these important thinkers at the
same time that's why today's episode is
going to be so much fun Our Guest is
William eggington who's a professor
colleague of mine at John's Hopkins
where he's a professor of literature
he's written a whole bunch of books the
most recent one of which is the rigor of
angels bores Heisenberg Kant and the
ultimate nature of reality so one
wonders if one knows a little bit about
verer Heisenberg Amman wiant and Jorge
Luis bores what those folks have to do
with each other and so we're going to
find that out I'm going to give you a
little hint a little spoiler here it has
to do with the fact that when we
perceive reality we don't perceive it in
a clear unadulterated form right we
perceive certain aspects of reality I
like to think I'm not someone who thinks
that all of reality is an illusion or
everything we see is an illusion we
perceive something and there's something
that has to do with reality but it's not
unmediated it's not immediate it's not
the fundamental nature of things just
staring us right in the face so we have
to do some work we have to do philosophy
science maybe even literature to
understand our relationship to the
fundamental nature of reality and that's
something that all three of these folks
talked about so the limitations on how
we can grasp reality is the theme
underlying this show and I think it went
very well and also it's just fun to do a
Humanities episode we don't often do
that if you don't count philosophy as
Humanities maybe you should but a more
literary kind of episode so I think
maybe we should do more of these that's
the lesson that I learned anyway so
let's
[Music]
go Willam megon welcome to the mindscape
podcast thanks Sean it's great to be
here so I think we'll go separately into
each of your three subjects of your new
book but let's start by bringing them
together Kant Heisenberg bores why in
the world of all the people throughout
history would you pick those three to
combine together into a book I know this
is always the first question it's my
first question in fact uh as I as I look
at the title of the book why those three
and uh they they they came they came to
me rather than me coming to them uh I
spent years talking about thinking about
reading into the philosophic iCal
questions at the heart of this book and
when the time came to put together the
structure of the book I spent a long
time thinking about who are going to be
the main vehicles I I knew that I wanted
to write something in the form of
narrative narrative non-fiction I'd done
this before I'd done an intellectual
biography of Miguel cantes that
explained what his contributions were to
the history of thought but did so via
telling the story of his life and I like
that format um so uh the first stab at
it um actually was was in some ways too
broad I had too many characters on the
table I was going back as far as Zeno
who and many of these characters still
make um entrances in the book but not to
the same extent as the three main
characters back as far as Zeno up as far
as Einstein and and Heisenberg and um my
thought after putting together the the
structure was it was it was too
scattered it it it lacked a through line
it needed to have a through line that
was more than just the philosophical
ideas that was exploring did you already
have a title at that point cuz I I
always start with the title I can't
write a book if I in fact the title
that's a great question the title was
was something that I struggled with for
ages and uh and but again both the title
and the fact that three characters ended
up finding me in a way um and so after
having first written this massive
outline with different characters for
each of 12 chapters jumping out
throughout sort of a time machine
through history um then I reeled it back
in and I said maybe I can do the same
thing by focusing on one guy and I
really like this philosopher from uh
from the 4th Century
boethus um the consolations of Phil
consolations of philosophy it's a great
book I've taught it in great books at
Hopkins many times and it brings me and
again another philosopher who really
makes makes it into this book as well
but in a in a very small part and then I
realized it's too remote uh too little
is known uh about this philosopher it
would be very hard to make you know his
life struggles without making up a whole
lot of stuff right uh uh present for the
um for the readers and then saw I was
thinking well you know I I I've always
loved this book um uh by Douglas
hoffstead um gerle shabbach said three
characters who were kind of weaved
together coming from different
disciplines I had always thought sort of
one of the ideas behind this is bringing
science and and philosophy and
literature together okay what if I had a
poet a physicist and a philosopher and
then it hit me about 10 years ago in the
the stone the the New York Times online
philosophy Forum I had actually written
a piece about kind of some of the
fundamental problems in the book and
there they were all three of the
characters were there bores had written
about Kant in that uh uh in that little
article and Heisenberg and so I said
well that's it because these are these
are characters who are they've LED
exciting lives we know a ton about them
um you know several of them I've
overlapped with in my own life two of
the three you never met any of I didn't
meet them no but but I could have met
bores I mean honestly I lived in the um
DC area in the uh in the early 80s and
and bores made it to um to Hopkins
Hopkins is a great Center for literary
uh studies and he was in the early 80s
he was he was brought here by the uh I
want to say The English Department or
for colleagues in the then Humanities
Center and uh he was blind and
completely blind by that uh by that
point I recount in the book he was
brought down to to pose grave at his own
request and put his hand on the on the
the face of the statue and this is this
is the PO that I know so yeah these
these were characters that I felt that I
could um really connect with that we
knew a lot about that I could get into
and uh and that's what what what ended
up calling to me about those particular
uh those particular characters so first
was the idea first the the questions and
then the characters and then to your
other question what about the title
because as you said you like to have the
title first I in many cases I I do too
in this case it was eluding me I just
couldn't find the right title and uh and
again it was something that it found me
because as I thought about some of these
issues I've been thinking and writing
and um uh teaching about this I I
recalled many many years ago having
given a lecture about one of the stories
that ends up being in fact I quote from
the epigraph and it's it's where I get
the title from Boris Umar obus and I had
called that lecture a rigor of angels
kind of with the idea as if you a murder
of crows a rigger of
angels That's What Angels would be and I
don't think that is it's probably a
Congregation of angels but uh but a
rigor of angels and and then I thought
no the rigor of angels uh and and as for
reasons we can probably get into more in
depth that was the right title for all
the all sorts of reasons both the sound
of it and that I found it evocative and
and poetic and at the same time it
really went to the heart of what um what
I was identifying as connecting these
three thinkers and you mentioned they
all resonated with the fundamental
problems of the book yeah what are the
fundamental problems of the book where
right and and so so I suppose we can get
into that by thinking about that title
the uh the rigor of angels is part of it
it's in some ways I describe it as kind
of a a negative title or a title about
what's not the answer to the ultimate
nature of reality right the uh the the
Assumption or the presumption or the
Prejudice that bores is dealing with
when he writes that sentence and the
famous sentence comes at the end or the
postcript of the story
umos he says that Humanity uh believes
that there's rigor in the world
um and indeed there is rigor in the
world but Humanity forgets and forgets
again that it is a rigor of Chess
Masters and not of Angels by which he
means that what this is now paraphrasing
Heisenberg and this is why the two come
together so well about this what we are
doing when we do science and we tend to
forget this is that we're not studying
nature itself but nature as it reveals
itself to our forms of knowledge or
instruments of observation and like and
then Kant came into it uh because that's
really what kant's critical philosophy
was all about right diving into that uh
with a with with a sort of critical
knife and dissecting those parts of our
knowledge which um we can feel safe
about uh talking about and those that we
should really be careful because we're
tending to let reason trample over the
the borders of what's reasonable to talk
about so we can think of the issue as
the intermediation of our observation in
between the world as it is and the world
we think about it is that overclaiming
or oversimplifying it's not over
overclaiming or oversimplifying I think
what happens is we can we can accept and
say that to a certain extent but we
still have a tendency then once we're in
the act of observing and talking about
our observations to then forget that
what we're talking about is our
observations right and and start to talk
and think and believe as though that
filter that intermediary position we're
no longer there and it sounds really
simple when you put it in those abstract
terms but then when you dive into it you
see over and over again we tend to do
the same thing which is to sort of then
start with the filter use it really
really well and then implicitly move it
out of the way and start talking as if
we didn't have the filter any yeah
exactly okay so let me before we get
into the substance here I want to sort
of ask an inside baseball for us
professors kind of question you know in
science there's a very clear delineation
between your research work and writing a
trade book for the masses in the
humanities I get the feeling it's less
clear I mean how do you think about this
contribution is this mostly explicating
things for the person on the street or
is this an academic contribution some
gosh for me honestly it's equally both
um but that's because I I I don't want
to generalize and say that that's
something that Humanities professors in
general are doing I would say that the
the majority at a school like Hopkins of
my colleagues um would be very insistent
on saying no the kind of work that I do
is is research it's research in a a
particular and highly defined um area of
the humanities it requires a great deal
of specialization and um and practice
and years and years of reading the
literature in order to get to this point
and that's that's something that's
extremely important and that they
probably would make a distinction
between doing that and uh and writing a
book that in my case was published by
Pantheon and that's sort of out there
and and being reviewed and read as I
hope and wanted to be by the general
public um so what I've been trying to do
now for I would say getting close to
half my career after a number of books
that were um in the former sense really
very specialized books of kind of you
know the interstices of literature and
and philosophy what we call kind of uh
critical theory um I do a lot with
psychoanalysis I'm just interested in
20th century European Philosophy for
example and uh which tends to be a kind
of very literary philosophy with a
literary bent um I wrote a series of
books that I'm proud of that I'm you
know that often come back in my in my
thinking and and teaching um but that
were read mostly by colleagues and
graduate students and uh what by librar
not bought by libraries exactly um that
uh um a review like Journal like kirus
if and when it would review and in some
cases it did would uh would tend to use
the word
impenetrable and um and at a certain
point when I got invited to write in the
uh in the stone and and then had several
years of doing repeat uh performances in
the stone in the New York Times and then
I I I honed my writing a little bit more
and found I could also uh publish the
occasional oped in the times what I
found was it was a challenge that I
really liked um and that most
importantly was actually a challenge
there was nothing about um dumbing down
oh it's not easier no it was actually
much harder and and the writing itself
took longer and I liked the both the
effect um the outcome I liked the kind
of writing that I was producing but I
also found that going through the
process of working my thoughts into that
form made them so much clearer for
myself and then began to seem to me that
some of my past writing was relying on
say jargon or relying on maybe skipping
steps in in um in thinking through a
problem um by by using a kind of
shorthand that I felt that my colleagues
and students would totally understand
but that we would hadn't necessarily all
really thought through all of the steps
so I began to really like the process as
a way of of of actually finding out more
about the world and it became a kind of
of research the rigor of angels just
like the man who invented fiction I
still believe that they should count as
as academic books as well um they have
an awful lot of footnotes right the the
the the footnote section in the rigor of
angels is many uh uh dozens uh of of
pages of uh of many many hundreds of
sources um those sources I think the uh
the fellow that I work with um on my on
my back matter who helps me organize the
notes and said this was uh uh he was
happy to report the book that forced him
to work with the most languages he'd
ever worked on right I think he counted
10 when you included Russian and Greek
and uh uh which are not languages that I
claim that I can read but we went to the
original Source material in some cases
so I really do feel that they're
researched books that they're uh uh
you're doing scholarship they're doing
scholarship but also doing it
simultaneously in a way where the
readership doesn't have to be Scholars
right yeah right yeah no I love that
answer I have the same issues in my mind
like I said it's even more clear in
science but I do take inspiration from
people like Douglas H Daniel Dennett
people who are clearly doing
intellectual work out there in a way
that the public and these are some of
the same people that I've taken
inspiration from and honestly you as
well oh well I'm I'm trying we'll we'll
see okay good so then back to the
substance of it and let's just dig a
little bit deeply into the three people
we're talking about so you have emmanu
Kant I've heard of him uh famously you
know influential philosopher a little
bit difficult for people to W their
minds about writes these giant criti
of reason and um probably if the person
on the street knew anything about uel K
it would be the categorical imperative
right a sort of deontological approach
to morality but that is just not the
aspect if I'm if I'm not mistaken that
you're interested in for this book
certainly not exclusively although uh
again following on what I said before
about learning more by using this method
of of of researching right I actually
ended up um teaching myself a lot lot
more about the entire Conan system uh by
virtue of wanting to dive into the
epistemological problem right so um the
entire Conan system is is vast as you
know but it's often divided into
Aesthetics uh epistemology and uh and
ethics and as you just pointed out I
think very correctly um the K that most
people know about is the ethical K the K
who's responsible for like the entire H
one entire half of the two ways of
thinking about ethics right we think
about onology versus what everything
else is consequentialism right but Kant
has deontology right it's that's that's
his wheelhouse that's that's his Corner
um and so you know and this is this is
true I I'd actually dealt a lot with
conent ethics before I'd been um going
for years to my kids former private
school and and invited to a course for
seniors on ethics and they always wanted
me to come and talk about K and it was
always a lot of fun because people get
up in arms about it he's you can't
really be saying this right these sorts
of things the consequences don't matter
what matters is a pure will what did you
intend and uh uh and then the
categorical imperative that you can you
have the sort of algorithm that you can
run your uh your thought processes
through and then you kind of test
whether uh whether you're being ethical
or not based on whether you can
universalize a maximum According to
which you acted or not it turns out and
you're right by saying that's not what
my original interest in in K was it's
the epistemological question of what can
we know and how sure can we be about
what we know that the obsessive question
of the critique of pure reason the first
great uh critique that he wrote what
happens as you read through this
carefully and and and work out the
arguments behind it is that that book
has already laid the groundwork for
everything else that he's going to do
and it in fact lays the groundwork for
what eventually becomes the ethics and
it lays the groundwork for what
eventually becomes the aesthetic Theory
the uh the the book on Judgment of
Judgment of the power of judg and then I
I felt not not just obligated it was
natural for me to try and show how all
of these arguments flow from the initial
problem of of knowledge for Kant um and
and as a result of doing that the book
followed this path
into um kind of existential questions of
human being right of what it is to be a
human in the world uh lost in space and
time uh always reaching for some kind of
certainties that would some in some
sense from the perspective of being lost
in space and time a drift in space and
time seemed to be anchors outside of
space and time or at least anchors that
would uh guide one in space in time and
it's that same relationship between the
D driess of being and the presumption of
certain points of certainty that allow
one to make judgments that is in fact
the exact same pivot that works in all
of the conent system and so by
discovering that the conent system
started to become clear to me and then I
said well part of what I'm trying to do
in this book is make it clear to
everybody that's good but let's but
let's make let's make it clear to
everyone what exactly that first move is
I mean what would Kant tell us if he had
a elevator pitch about
epistemology so this is what he would
tell us in fact this is what he does
tell us um Kant uh Begins the critique
of pure reason some very famous uh
introductions and then Rewritten
introductions from the end of the of the
same decade so we're talking about the
decade of the 1780s to 1790 um he's been
thinking and thinking and reading and
promising this book for years and years
and years and people are beginning to
fret and they're say what is what is
happening when is this book going to
come out and then it finally lands and
everyone's there's this is collective
what is that right no one can really get
it because it's so big and so
complicated and then bit by bit people
start to become clear and so what k then
describes at the beginning of the book
is he sort of he describes this moment
that he then he calls this uh his own
cernic Revolution and this cernic
revolution is provoked by having been in
a kind of um at a time in his career
been in a situation of sort of yeah we
know all of this of certainty and uh uh
he called it he refers to it as dogmatic
Slumber very famously and dogmatic
Slumber refers to dogmatism what uh uh
rationalism uh he he was part of a
school of philosophers who believed that
and this is me paraphrasing it but uh
the world as we sense it is an
expression of some kind of an ultimate
reason or ultimate code right um and we
they didn't have machines like we have
now but one way of think it would be
thinking about it would be like a matrix
like World um that everything that we
experience is is like the decoding of
some kind of very complex uh uh language
someone namely God speaks that language
knows that language if you could be God
you would then see and Inuit it
everything right and so out of of these
fundamental laws everything that you
experience would flow naturally there
would be no distinction at all between
the experience of the world and the
world itself uh as Kant admits he was
sort of he had drunk the Kool-Aid he was
part of that uh that that group and then
he read David Hume and was Gob
smacked David Hume had come to entirely
the opposite conclusion right and he
challenged everything about the sort of
the
self-c uh confidence of the Ral
uh what David Hume said is well uh every
time that I dive into an experience of
the world and try and find anything else
than just the experience itself I can't
find anything it's other than a
sensation other than a a feeling I can't
even find an eye that's feeling that
thing all there is are these what I
would call me again paraphrasing kind of
um sensual slivers of SpaceTime that's
it you're just being smacked by one
impression after the other and then we
have have the hubris this says David
Hume um to put those all together repeat
them several times on the basis of a few
miserable repetitions we think we know
the answers to the universe right we get
into habits and then we say oh because
of these uh I feel seen by we we do
exactly and Kant um famously said well
that uh that just woke me up right this
was a challenge he didn't like it not
one little bit he wanted to resist it
but he felt that it was massively
important argument and he needed to uh
um to face it in some way and so what he
came up with and this is what took him
so long was he realized no you know we
neither can know the world as it is out
there and its perfect code however nor
are we stuck just in this sort of wash
of of of sensual Hees and Nows and Hees
and Nows the argument that he used to
prove the latter why we can't just be
caught in that was a real Smackdown
argument it was absolutely brilliant
what he figured out what he realized is
if one were really only ever present for
one particular moment in SpaceTime those
slivers of SpaceTime and then again
another sliver of SpaceTime and another
sliver of SpaceTime you wouldn't even
know that you were just having one
sliver of SpaceTime after another
there'd be no there really would be no
you there to stitch them together but if
there's no you there there's no
synthesizing of anything over time accul
there's no accumulation whatsoever then
there's no experience so the mere fact
that we're experiencing anything means
that there must be something that he
then called conditions of possibility of
experiencing anything and those
conditions of possibility which he then
works out in the first part of this
magnificent book fundamentally uh our
space and time the forms of of intuition
these have aior structures to them these
you don't actually find in the world
through experience they are the
conditions of possibility of finding
anything in the world and once you have
those and causality is one of them you
start to build up a system that then can
make sense scientifically and that is
independent of the actual content that
you're finding out there in the world so
in a nutshell that was the problem and
that's also the problem that connected
for me to the other two characters in I
guess I probably should resist this
temptation but we're all friends here
we're having a good conversation I want
to argue against this right now it's
probably going to get us down a rabbit
hole but what I want to say being more
humean in proclivity is there is a give
and take between us and the world and
and hum is right that we have all these
Sensations and so forth but rather than
relying on AR priori conditions of
possibility to fix that problem I I
would tend to say like we come up with
hypotheses about structures out there in
the world you know we have some
intuitions we might revise them but it's
a constant dialectic between our models
of the world and these Sensations that
we get and I don't really need anything
AR priori other than a hope that there
are patterns out there to be discerned
that makes a lot of sense and I would
say say and again this is distilling the
conent position far more than than put
it this way but what what what is
fundamentally there uh of importance to
here is that there still has to be a
distinction between the knower and
what's being known right and the knower
is not exclusively just the object so to
speak in that situation right so this
this idea of something synthesizing the
different moments is already implicitly
problematic in human that's what that's
what pulls out right and and and these
the idea of the a priori becomes a big
problem it becomes a big problem for
Heisenberg when he's wrestling with Kant
uh uh uh later he will out and out and
say we had to move the border of the a
priori right but but he still accepts
this idea of this distinction the
distinction in that case between the
knowing subject and what can be known in
the world um one of the thought
experiments that I play around with is
again it's a very conent one but it's
also one that is brought to me by
reading K through thinking with bores a
lot um is the distinction between having
um a a memory and then actually reliving
that memory okay if one you you think
about some moment in the past that you
really enjoy it and now you try and
intensify that thought and intensify it
more and we've we've seen there's great
science fiction about this like in um
the the British series Black Mirror
right something you can kind of Click
into your mind and you now really
re-experience ing something but if you
push that all the way um you get to a
point and I'm sure you see where I'm
going where that fullon
experience five cents full
Technicolor immersion in that moment in
the past if it's really going to be
absolutely perfect it's no longer a
memory and you're just doing it again
and not only are you just doing it again
they're not doing it again again there's
no again there anymore you've lost
whatever distinction is there between
the subject object who can actually
enjoy this a as a memory and simply
being in it and it's that minimal
distance that's required ultimately for
anything that we would call perception
as well so you sort of intensify that
and bring that moment of the past right
up into the present and you realize in
that what what Kant was saying is
something has to be different between
the knower and what's being known in
order for known experience perceived to
be known experience perceived in the
first place have you read David Cher's
book reality plus do you know about it I
have not read that one no he's arguing
that in fact a virtual reality
experience sufficiently real is just
real yeah you know there the ways that
you get your Sensations and your
experiences and whatever are almost
immaterial uh I don't know whether I go
along with it or not but I am
sympathetic and and that plus in in that
formulation and thank you for the
recommendation I'm going to run out and
read it but that plus is really what
what ends up being Frant the the what he
calls the pure point of app
that's it's the fact that something
whatever it is Remains the Same long
enough for a difference to be registered
that kind of pivot is is what we would
call the human subject okay well you've
given us a a nice segue into person
number two who I'm going to nominate to
be Heisenberg Heisenberg and borase are
pretty contemporary in some sense very
much so actually yeah very much so but
as you said well I'm I'm going to put
you on the spot here do you want to
summarize Heisenberg's contributions put
this is where I always feel especially
talking to you I'd rather just pass the
mic over to you but I'll do my best and
uh subject to the you know the physicist
Corrections of course the greatest
contributions from Heisenberg came in
1925 or at least in published form 25
and 27 in 25 he worked out what he was
calling at the time um Matrix mechanics
what became known as quantum mechanics
um uh he was uh he decided as he said at
the beginning of that famous article
that uh um he put it in I think in the
passive but uh uh it occurred it was
sort of the thought occurred right the
thought occurred knows how happened to
sequence to to to essentially to put it
in in layman's language to to to think
about to work out not uh uh what's
happening as if we had position momentum
of of of particles like electrons but
rather to look at frequencies and kind
of work backwards from from frequencies
and when you what was so complicated
about the mathematics is that the
frequencies have a lot more variables
than just uh a position of momentum so
you start having to multiply um strings
of uh of numbers uh columns and rows of
numbers instead of uh uh individuals and
um something weird happens when you do
it in One Direction you get a different
answer from when you do it in the other
direction his his uh computations
weren't commuting uh even though
according to the rules of arithmetic
they were supposed to commute and yet
they were still accounting for the
experimental results right and so he
wrote a paper saying we should do this
anyway because I'm getting the right
answers and let's kind of stop worrying
about what's happening between the
before and after measurements and just
stick with that because it
works um and then I think it was draak
who um uh kind of boiled all these
amazing calculations down to something
kind of sub sublimely beautiful and
simple and impossible to understand
which was XP minus PX uh equals uh I so
the imaginary uh uh uhare < TK of1 * uh
H bar um and everyone who looks at it
says yeah well that's it in a nutshell
and it doesn't make any sense right
right I taught it in my class literally
this morning so it it is kind of an
important thing and and it's it's an
amazing amazing equation that sort of
carries everything about the the that
Discovery in in a nutshell there is no
way to make an observation of the one
starting with uh with position and then
do your multiplications by momentum um
and do it in a way that if you then go
back and do it the other way around
you're going to get the same answer so
there's always that minimal difference
that sort of results were were in some
ways for me and maybe now I'm starting
to philosophize already about it but
right that minimal difference that that
already Imports into the act of or of
obtaining Knowledge from the world
something about the agency not in any
kind of a metaphysical sense but right
of of uh the one who's acting or the
action on the world required to get that
Knowledge from the world and I will say
even though I'm the professional
physicist of course we physicists have
never read these papers by Heisenberg or
whatever we never read the original
papers so you have that advantage and
they're very difficult I mean right well
I think my experience when I have
written books of my own and been forced
for the first time to read some of the
classic papers is they're wildly varying
in approachability like some people
could write like boltzman was great
right but and heis not so great and I
mean even I've got this not so great in
writing in an understandable way
thinking these these thoughts but but
he's he's a clunky writer and you know
this I'm going through this with my
students right now we're reading this is
the English translation uh but physics
and philosophy which I think is an
extraordinary book by Heisenberg by
Heisenberg massive fantastic book um but
since we're read I mean Kant is a
difficult writer but he's not clunky in
the way that that Heisenberg is uh
there's certain Elegance difficult but
elegance and then of course bores so
there's oh that's not fair it's like at
a different level you know so they all
have their different areas of strengths
and sort of just a clear Exposition in a
in a in a beautiful German is not what I
would call Heisenberg's great uh great
strength I don't know if you ever read
Zen In The Order Motorcycle Maintenance
did where he uh where feed refers toan
walant as the master Diamond Cutter
right he was able to like exactly find
the the Precision the Precision of the
language is extraordinary it really is
and that's also a difficulty in
Translation because we do come up with
translations that um I mean David
Lindley has this amazing book on
certainty uhhuh um I really like it it's
beautiful my students uh in the in the
first year seminar started off with this
but even Lindley I think maybe he
doesn't and and I would you know take
this back if I had a conversation with
him and he said no no no I I really did
understand this but in the in the
portion where he's talking about the
title of the paper we were just
discussing um there's a a word in German
ansha ansha is sometimes translated as
perpetual sorry perceptual not Perpetual
perceptual sometimes as intuitive and um
Lindley says who got intuitive that kind
of doesn't make any sense uh and and the
the reason that it in some ways does
make sense is that um in the standard
translations of Kant um what what are
referred to as the uh a priori forms of
intuition space and time are referring
exactly to ansha to this idea of what
comes in through our senses to us in the
in the world that there must be a form
for that and that is I think in a very
intentional way what Heisenberg is
getting to with this with this use of
ansha in that in that title so it's not
intuitive in the sense of um what we
tend to think of oh an intuition I have
a hunch I have an intuition right it's
not about hunches right it's about the
form that um the outside world whatever
it is is kind of forced to take in order
to be gred by us in the first place so
you know I've long been fetching about
the fact that uh the world has not
really taken quantum mechanics seriously
in in a fundamental way and those years
of the 1920s Etc were're just remarkable
and we're going to have to keep studying
them over and over again because you can
see very clearly Heisenberg and Bor and
pal and and the friends were fitting the
data like you said but they were also
carrying out a revolution in
epistemology and
metaphysics and maybe they went too far
I think they went too far honestly and
they were they would complain about
people like shinger and Einstein who are
kind of still trying to understand how
the world really worked like that's not
we've decided that's not what we do
anymore and and you can buy half of that
program without the other half I agree
with that and and I think the idea of
throwing out how the world really works
is not is not something that I would um
wholeheartedly Embrace I think it's the
cautionary know the critical if you will
in the Conan sense of saying just be
really careful about what you presume
right that you care right the
assumptions that you carry with you
about the world and I think you know in
those moments of these great I mean I
couldn't agree more with you about just
how great it is to relive and and dive
back into all that's happening in these
heady moments from the mid 20s to the
mid-30s with the the salv conferences
and you just want to go back in time and
have been a fly on the wall or or a guy
drinking wine at the table is these
conversations were going on in Belgium
yeah um it was beer it was Belgium beer
good Belgium beer right um but uh uh
that that the one sees in reading
through these accounts how very much
influenced Einstein in particular during
those debates was by a a sense a gut
feeling he had of how the kind of the
world in itself must be right and so
it's not that I would say and I think in
some ways the Copenhagen Copenhagen ites
were probably pushed or push themselves
to the extremity of their own positions
in part and kind of by you know in a
dialectic with with with Einstein and
shinger right uh and I think with the
with 2020 hindsight we can we can say
well look there's there's actually
something to be gathered to be
appreciated about about both sides
absolutely certainly the Acuity with
which I Einstein threw one
curveball after another at the
Copenhagen nightes to try and get them
to rethink their problems push science
forward in IM I mean immeasurably I've
occasionally thought that you know in
some sense when the United States came
into being we had the Constitutional
Convention we were pretty lucky really
that we had such smart cookies you know
there who people who really read
classical philosophy Etc in a way that
we wouldn't now if we tried to do it
again and likewise I think we were we
were pretty lucky as a race to have such
thoughtful people there at the dawn of
quantum mechanics you know Heisenberg
but also Bor and Einstein and and
schinger these people really thought
things through at such a deep level that
again I'm skeptical that we would pull
off now and I and I share your concern
and one of the reasons I think that they
were so that they had the kind of
insights that they were able to produce
was was that they they transcended their
own specializations yes they were all
absolutely the top of their game in the
kind of physics that they were doing but
they were all thinkers as well and more
than thinkers in some cases I mean
Heisenberg was a could have been a
concert pianist right and he was a real
musician and and not to mention that he
was clocking apparently extraordinary
times on the uh ski slopes right when
when they would take a break from doing
physics apparently Einstein was not a
concert level violinist no apparently
not I wasn't going to make the same
claim for him but he loved playing
Mozart right and and ber loved playing
his uh his beopen so and you mentioned a
connection between Kant and Heisenberg I
mean how explicit was that did
Heisenberg read Kant and that did that
directly influence him yes he did um he
read more classical philosophy of first
because his father was a Classics uh uh
Professor by which we mean the Greeks
and the r the Greeks exactly and uh he
he read the physical theories of Plato
in the timeus and he was kind of not
overly impressed at first but then at
toward the very very end of his life he
was thinking actually it was some of you
know puzzling over these philosophical
problems in uh in Plato that
actually helped me helped loosen me or
loosen the grip that um the what he
would refer refer to as kind of the
erector set model of atoms and uh uh and
molecules had on me and allowed me to
think a little bit more freely but Kant
was absolutely very uh influential and
in fact some of the most important
conversations um that occurred
after the the Great Discovery so in the
1930s and then into the 1940s was was
Heisenberg with um uh philosophers with
members of the Vienna Circle and then
also with neoc contians uh and um they
were at odds but in a very interesting
and pro um productive way um I'm
thinking in particular of the debates
that took place I think they were in
leig I think uh CLA H hamon came to leig
and a very highly publicized series of
conversations public conversations
between one of the the crown thinkers of
Neo the ne conans and uh and the
inventor of quantum mechanics um with uh
Fred Von vit the um assistant and good
friend and also philosopher as well as
physicist of uh of of um of Heisenberg
and I think via in particular had a a
formative influence as well I think he
had read Kant probably more thoroughly
than uh um than Heisenberg in this uh
book physics and philosophy um
Heisenberg goes into some length uh uh
and and draws the parallels between his
thinking about the world on the basis of
his discover their discoveries because
he never takes credit for anything for
the most part it seems like and uh and
and K and as I said that's where he
makes this comment about um uh we have
to change kind of what we're thinking
about when we think about a priori but
the distinction still needs to remain
between the the the knower and what can
be known with some degree of certainty
in the uh in the outside world um so
he's thinking about these these issues
very carefully but I think um via would
later say and this I thoroughly agree
with him about that um their thinking
together was coming closer and closer to
K all along I'll mention for podcast
regulars that Greta Herman's name has
come up before she does make a brief
appearance in the history of quantum
mechanics as the first person to point
out that John F man's supposed proof
about the impossibility of hidden
variables didn't work and no one no one
believed her and it was I didn't know
that yeah yeah she she said this and no
one listened and fyman had written this
book saying you can't do hidden
variables and the only person besides
gret Herman who wrote an article about
it who appreciated F neyman's mistake
was Einstein wow and Einstein pointed
out vman's mistake to David B who had
written a textbook mentioning Fan's
proof and David bone went off and
invented bowan mechanics and that
inspired John Bell and that's why we won
the Nobel Prize last year for
entanglement and Etc so okay just if
people remember the name that's where
it's from that's that's terrific and I
did not realize that what what what did
come out of this conversation was it
with this absolutely fascinating moment
where um because again in the spirit of
good dialogue Hamond is asking questions
that are forcing uh Heisenberg to really
stake his claims in very clear language
and she at some point says well then
what is an adom and his answer is we
don't really have the language to to say
with want to talk about what things
really are that was that was that was a
big leap philosophically so therefore
Let's uh put it all in poetic terms
where where does how does bores fit into
this or I mean let's he might be the
least familiar character to this
audience so tell us who bores is that's
an interesting point I hadn't thought
about that so bores backing up a little
bit um bores is from Argentina uh he uh
grew up when he was very young for a
little while in Switzerland uh moved
back to to
Argentina felt very Argentinian um uh
wrote poetry wanted to be a poet uh he
wrote poetry that uh in some ways was
very kind of rooted in his own culture
at the beginning uh and he had middling
success he was shy he was I guess what
we would refer to nowadays as kind of a
nebish a little bit clumsy um uh deeply
passionate and and would often fall in
love and almost always the love was
unrequited uh and he would write one
book after another he would have a close
group of Associates who would um really
really appreciate what he was doing and
for the most part they would land with
the kind of great big thud of Silence uh
on the critical World until when he was
around 60 years old out of nowhere a
book that he had on the basis of some
books that he had published in the early
1940s um a new literary prize had been
invented by a whole group of the world's
most prominent uh Publishers in Europe
and um his work had been making the
rounds in France it had been some of it
had been translated by um uh people in
sat's group in Le down in uh in Paris um
in particular by a a now quite famous
French philosopher uh Ro Caya and all of
a sudden um out comes the Publishers uh
the the the international Publishers
prize for the first time the first ever
uh the inaugural International
Publishers prize with an ungodly sum of
money for that time I think it was
$10,000 or something like that um
squarely split between uh two authors
and one of them was someone no one in
the rest of the world had heard of Jorge
Luis bores from uh from Argentina and he
instantaneously this was was along with
Samuel Becket with the other who people
had heard right uh instantaneously
became the most famous man in in
Argentina and uh from there his Fame
only grew people went to the back
catalog and started reading all these
extraordinary stories that he had
written over the years um and then the
next thing he became a fixture on
American campuses and uh um he uh he
died some 20 25 26 years later the most
famous man in Argentina overnight
success
60 60 plus overnight success he now had
that that success had started to build
at the beginning of the 1940s from a
series of publications of a kind of new
kind of story that he'd um invented and
it he invented it out out of a a a
number of different interests that he
had he had been writing stories before
but he had also been writing essays and
they were essays based on really
in-depth readings that he would do in uh
in philosophy in theology uh Deep dive
into problem mathematics he was a huge
fan of bur and Russell and he would read
these books that he often got from his
father's Library exhaustively he would
consume them and then he would sit and
think about the problems that they
created for him and then he would write
essays about them and then bit by bit he
started messing with the essay form
until he came up with a kind of mange a
synthesis between essay and story
there's sometimes fictional essays
sometimes stories that seem to have the
trappings of uh uh of an essay but what
they do is they are stories that were
collected in a group that's now called
fictions um that was published in 1941
and 44 in two different uh sets these
stories um are kind of the ultimate
metaphysical thought experiments he'll
take certain problems and um
presumptions that we say have about the
world or the way the world is and then
he'll just start in a kind of gadfly or
sort of impish way pushing them further
and F further so the reason that this is
a general introduction to bores now
specifically what does bores have to do
with these other two thinkers it's
really bores who led me to them in a way
I uh I like to say that um I'm maybe one
of the only people in the world who was
taught how to understand quantum
mechanics by reading
bores might not we don't know but yeah
and then and then through that kind of
then went back and and read K and
realized okay Kant is getting at this
from a philosophic in a philosophical
language as well so the story uh I try
to introduce the readers to the
understanding that I have of quantum
mechanics um and then ultimately some of
these other big cosmological problems
that Bor has led me to as well through
the story that uh that launched me in
that direction and it's a story about a
man who can't forget um and there's some
evidence that boras was influenced by
stories that were circulating
internationally at the time about a man
am menist animist uh named uh Solomon
shareski a Moscow journalist um who uh
was called out at a meeting One Day by
his editor because he was not taking
notes and sheski says I don't know what
you mean I don't need to take notes and
the editor was angry at him and said
tell me what you know what do you
remember and he proceeded word by word
to recount the entirety of the uh
morning the morning meeting without
missing a b a bit of it and so sher's uh
memory Feats were sort of making it
around the world and I think that's many
scholars think that word got to bores
and he invented a story about a man who
who literally can't forget so he sort of
takes this idea of someone with a really
vast extraordinary memory but pushes it
even further and he's that because he's
intellectually curious what would it
really be like not to be able to forget
well one of the first things that bores
realizes is not being able to forget
quickly impedes upon perception itself
so not being able to forget is also kind
of like not being able to not perceive
anything so because to be able to
perceive CeCe something
involves uh putting aside something else
for a moment but this guy that he
creates FES is the name of the character
story an anonomous story FES the
memorius FES can't not perceive
absolutely everything and he also can't
not forget absolutely everything but
that creates a problem because then the
the temporal uh the now moment in which
he's perceiving is constantly being
invaded by the past moments that he also
can't get out of his mind and he becomes
very becomes very difficult for him to
to distinguish between the two and Boris
starts to play with his the way that he
does with kind of The Logical conundrums
that are created by this as he put
points out at one point in the story FES
Could reconstruct an entire day in fact
he done so on several occasions the
problem was to reconstruct an entire day
he needed an entire
day and that really kind of puts the
problem of of of perfect perception kind
of in a nutshell for you right and it's
this idea that the very idea of perfect
perception is it CR crumbles under its
own incoherent exactly it becomes
incoherent right in fact there becomes
very little difference between something
like perfect perception or Perfect
Memory and perfect forgetting or perfect
Oblivion right you can't you need to be
somewhere in between the two in order to
be knowing or learning anything about
the world so what what what boras did
with that story is he really focused in
for me on the question philosophical
question of what is an observation what
constitutes kind of the minimal
conditions of something like an
observation and it would be that you
have something that in Ence something
thing or some person or some point that
remains unchanged long enough in order
to register changes in SpaceTime but in
order to do so it also can't be
identical to those changes in in
SpaceTime and hence whatever knowledge
or impression is coming out of that must
have some sort of a minimal difference
carried in it right and uh and obviously
what I do is there's no mathematics in
that there's no attempt to say and hey
Presto I've discovered through Bor is
right the uncertainty principle but
there's a lot in common about that that
somewhere at the there's a there's
there's a limit to how close you can get
to reality right and that uh that that
limit is not something that we can get
out we can kind of erase and somehow
then eventually get perfect knowledge
it's built in it's baked into the
structure of knowing the real
I think yeah I always have mixed
feelings about this particular
connection to Quantum Mechanics like I
truly mixed positive as well as negative
right I do think that immanu Wan did not
know about quantum mechanics right he
was talking about a different thing than
the fundamental laws of physics it was
it was you know our human access to the
world and then so I I think it' be wrong
to give people the impression that
quantum mechanics is a version of the
same problems we had in the classical
world world but it's more like it takes
advantage of the fact that our
observations are necessarily incomplete
and and change the world like it there
was some room there that we didn't know
was there that quantum mechanics kind of
uh makes use of in an unanticipated way
I like that I like that specification I
would say that the the room there that
we didn't know was there that there are
thinkers in history who kind of showed
that it had to be there right that there
was no getting closer to it in a way and
that's that's as close as the similarity
comes but it's a pretty profound
similarity nonetheless I guess would be
would be my position and did bores uh
again interact directly with either Kant
or Heisenberg Kant absolutely and you
even see one or two references to the
name but then the the philosophy is all
there he claims um and you never know
with Bor you never know he was
mischievous that's right he was very
mischievous but he claims that he
learned to read German by reading the
critique of pure reason yeah I don't
believe yeah we don't believe that right
but along with another another uh novel
um uh by by G Gustaf Gustaf I think my
rink um called de golum so the gum uh
which also is a a myth of of um sort of
Promethean Promethean Jewish myth about
uh a rabbi in Prague who um who
recreates life but because it's a
recreation as opposed to a creation um
does so very badly and creates uh
creates a monster there always
questionary Tales cautionary tales
exactly so this was written uh so it's
it's another version of the Frankenstein
uh myth way but um figures very
frequently in in one way or another in
bores but Kant is all over the place but
often UNAM Conan preoccupations with
certain problems uh but from time to
time uh Boris does focus in on Kant and
what he in particular focuses focuses in
on is a part of the critique of pure
reason that um one would be forgiven for
thinking that in some ways Heisenberg in
he when he says critical things about
Kant simply failed to read or or just
isn't thinking about that because we
talked a lot about the analytic side of
which is the first half of the book it's
the book in which it's the part of the
book in which Kant says um you know he
he he saves what science can know uh uh
from this this humean uh uh attack but
the other side of the book is truly the
critical side it's called the dialectic
and it's the dialectic of pure reason is
all the problems that we're going to run
into when we forget to be critical MH
when we forget that there are these kind
of limits built into what uh knowledge
uh uh one of the forms of those those
problems that they arise in he calls
anies bores unlike Heisenberg who didn't
pay much attention to enemies didn't pay
much attention to OB there's this whole
other side of kant's philosophy that
says you're going to make all sorts of
mistakes and all sorts of weird things
are going to happen when you allow your
presumptions about the way the world
should be to kind of run ahead of uh of
of your observations um bis loves anti
[Laughter]
and in some ways what his stories kind
of one after the other do is something
like provoke us or push us to the edge
of an anamy and I think that's one of
the things that the aspects of boris's
writing that made me return to Kant and
and and read continent it's worth
mentioning B's probably most famous
story which is the library of Babel I
think right tell us about that so it's
um it's an extraordinary story it's uh
um one of the the ways that I deal with
the the Li well first of all just to
tell what the library of Babel is it's a
thought experiment about if you will
combinatory mathematics it's a a story
that makes it sound drier than it comes
across yeah you're you're right it's an
existential Journey Through Hell based
on the pro on problems that arise from
combinatory mathematics is that better
much better yes bores imagines a world
that is nothing but a library and that
library is uh nothing but books built
into hexagonal rooms each room having
four walls and then two doorways um each
of those walls having a certain number
of shelves each of those shelves holding
a certain number of books those books
being identical in size number of pages
Etc and um The Librarians who only know
the library and have never been anywhere
else and they March through and they
pick out books and they look at them and
then go on to others bit by bit have uh
formed a theory about the world that
they live in and the theory is that the
library contains one copy of every
single book that it's possible to make
with 22 orthographic symbols and all
those other constraints um and the other
uh uh theory is um uh that there no two
books in the library are the
same and then uh uh out of that so
simple set of constraints uh bores
creates as I said this kind of
existential Journey Through Hell where
he imagines generations and generations
of librarians searching through the
library for books that even have a
single word that makes sense to them
right or single string of of of of words
that come together and when they do
whole religions are founded on the
meanings of these and Prophets rise and
fall Wars battles are fought people are
thrown off the uh the balconies into the
the Nether world and he does come up
with also a a theory of the shape of the
library based on this at least that's
one of the claims that I make in the
book because he does refer to um the uh
neoplatonic idea of uh the universe
being a a sphere whose uh is everywhere
in circumference nowhere um he does make
the point that the Universe the library
which he says in the first sentence of
the story are the same um that it uh uh
it must be finite because there is a
finite number of these uh books and at
the same time it can't have a boundary
because they know the rules of the
library are such that all of the cells
of the library are the same and so it
can't have a boundary and if there's
something like that then it's going to
be this is what I argue in the book
hypers spherical in uh in in in its
shape right so and he makes this point
as well he he just in one sentence said
the universe must be finite and then
when people get thrown off the uh the
balconies and they fall they never end
falling he says that they fall for for
for an infinite amount of uh of time and
space so he creates this this world but
he also as I says in in in some ways
kind of points to tendencies that have
that in our sensemaking drive we are
likely to come up with mythologies
religions he comes up with this idea of
the man of the book or the the great
Bookman would be that somewhere in the
library there is a book that explains by
virtue of every possible book existing
that explains the library and that book
must have been read by someone and the
person who will have read or that that
book then becomes all knowing and is is
the man uh the book man and and and then
in some ways he says is look even if
it's not true no it's true because
otherwise you know if there's no
explanation to this you know let me be
torn apart let me die a a death of
desperation let me be tortured in hell
but let there be some justification for
this but if there is a book that
correctly explains the library in the
library there's also a huge number
vastly Huger number of books that
purport to explain the library and are
incorrect and bores himself points that
out right and there's going to be one
with one error in it right or one word
wrong and there's going to be many more
many many more like that exactly not and
so so one of my great findes ever and
it's not I'm not claiming that it's my
find someone recommended the book to me
uh but it's it it blew me away is is has
the title The inconceivable mathematics
of B and it's by a mathematician uh Eko
Umberto Ekko once said oh this is this
Library must be very big but it doesn't
really matter let's not think about that
but what this mathematician did was
actually do the combinatory mathematics
which are not that difficult and he
worked it out and the size of the of the
library is truly unimaginable right it's
it it at some point he makes and this is
very memorable he works it out and says
our known universe is about the size of
a proton in comparison with B is's
Universe yeah I mean that that just like
wow just the size of the thing yeah and
it does recall the memory story because
just like a full memory of a day takes
it today for the library the full card
catalog would be the same as the library
would be the same as the library no
compression possible no compression
possible and in fact this made me think
about something very this is very I talk
about it a little bit in the book but
not this what uh uh the specific example
that I'm going to mention right now I
was listening to um I think it was it
was on on the radio was a conversation
with between Brian Green the string
theorist and uh an interlocutor at the
92nd Street and he's green a former
mindscape podcast guest I'm sure and and
Brian who's I have many of his books
here and the the more recent one or the
most I think recent one until the end of
time I think he was this is a scenario
that he's describing in the end of time
or his interlocutor pressed him on this
he says this is a brilliant man with
some very strange ideas one of these
strange ideas uh the podcaster says is
that um here we are at the 92nd Y and he
describes the scenario he says somewhere
out there it's so far away you can't
even begin to think about it there is an
another scenario
with exactly the same kind of setup and
but maybe just one or two atoms off from
us and then there's another one just
unimaginably further out there and so
what he's playing with Brian there is
this idea that if the universe is indeed
infinite and there's a finite amount of
the kinds of stuff that you can build
things out of um that inevitably in that
Infinity because Infinity is just so
darn big the uh the configurations that
lead to us speaking here at this podcast
some very very similar version of it is
going to exist somewhere and some also
very uh similar version with just a few
changes going to exist somewhere else
and on and on and so on well to go to
your point
bores cites that problem many many years
ago and he cites it already from the
19th century he cites it specifically in
friedrick nich's theory of the eternal
return if he were more physically uh up
on it he would have cited boltzman
because it's really the B flating
Universe yeah yeah but so in in it's I
think what is interesting about cting n
there is that there's an existential
problem N is a perfectly eyes sited it's
okay too okay yeah it's okay too um he
drew moral implications fromal
implications from and and what B has is
sort of absolutely brilliant response to
this to this idea of infinity that's
being invoked there is as he says at one
point like an Infinity in uh in talking
about an infinite Universe uh in time
and space thinking forward that
something's GNA last for an infinite
amount of time or has lasted for an
infinite amount of time in some ways is
no different from saying Infinity to the
left of you to the right of you right uh
and that the the the problem that's
invoked or that's overlooked by n and
then I would extend this I guess in this
partic is as bores puts it in this
repeating because it's the eternal
return this repeating Universe in which
the same thing happens over and over
again in time is whether it's happened
for the first time or the 500th time or
the 10th to the 500th time you would
need a special Archangel watching over
you in order to tell right something
needs to have been the same during all
those transformations in order for that
new configuration to be a configuration
in the first place otherwise it's what
pragmatist would call like a difference
that doesn't make a difference right a
distinction that doesn't make a
difference yeah and so we're near in the
end here time to let our hair down and
bring it all together like what do we
learn by reading about all three of
these folks together limitations on our
knowledge you know we don't have an
unvarnished view of reality that's right
therefore what therefore when we're
whether we're doing science whether
we're engaging perhaps in in politics
whether we're thinking about our our
role or our existence in the world we
try to approach everything with a
certain amount of humility not presuming
that there is a way that things have to
be or a way that they are out there in
the world but rather that we're
constantly engaging in a very proactive
and constructive way in the realities
that we create be they social realities
but also scientific realities that
that's important for doing science well
is not to let your presumption of what
the answer should be get in the way of
the experimentation but in a similar way
in order to do personal interactions
well it's important not to let your
presumption of how those personal
interactions should be get in the way of
those interactions you sort of react to
things um with a kind of humility
patience understanding and always trying
to use the tools of your disposal the
tools of communication the tools of your
knowledge to make the best sense you can
given the situation I love that motto
actually uh because to put it in a less
generous form if we pick physicists
fiction writers and philosophers these
are three categories of people who often
help themselves to infinite knowledge
and Precision in ways that are not quite
wared right maybe this is a useful
corrective for us professionally as well
as personally I agree I agree all right
Bill lington thanks so much for being on
the M podcast real
[Music]
pleasure
love